what's up everyone this is Anthony
papiano
most of you know me as pump you're
listening to off the chain
simply the best podcasting crypto let's
kick this thing off the following is a
conversation with Jason Williams
co-founder and partner at Morgan Creek
digital in this conversation we discuss
building a half a billion dollar
healthcare company Thermal Demanufacture
dunkin donuts and Starbucks universal
health care plants as quantum computers
and what it was like being in a plane
crash I really enjoyed this conversation
and I hope you do as well skirt school
want to know who has the best URL crypto
comm that's right crypto comm
there are crypto platform with one goal
mother and mass adoption that's why
we're all here we're trying to get
crypto in every wallet crypto comm is
helping people do that through buying
earning lending and card payment
everything you could want at crypto comm
go help your boy out
tell them pump sent you download the app
or visit crypto comm pumps got you
always everyone to get into mining and
didn't know how don't worry your boy
pops gotcha everybody got some
electricity and Wi-Fi all you got to do
is go to coin mine comm you buy a coin
mine it's like an Xbox or a Playstation
that helps you turn your electricity
into Bitcoin that's right you purchase
it it shows up at your doorstep you pull
it out of the box you plug it in connect
to your Wi-Fi five minutes or less
you're mining Bitcoin all you have to do
is control it from the mobile app they
provide and then you receive
over-the-air updates that add new coins
and new features on a consistent basis
kind of like how Tesla does over-the-air
updates and updates the car software
just you're updating your coin mind
consumer mining made easy that's right
go to coin mine comm tell them tom sent
you and thank me later
anthony pomp leon o is a partner at
Morgan Creek digital all opinions
expressed by palm or his guests on this
podcast are solely their opinions and do
not reflect the opinions of Morgan Creek
digital or Morgan Creek
you should not treat any opinion
expressed by pomp as a specific
inducement to make a particular
investment or follow a particular
strategy but only as an expression of
his opinion this podcast is for
informational purposes only all right
guys
bang-bang one hundred fifty first
episode we're doing an anniversary week
of one year for the podcast we've had
one of my partner's Marcuse go come on
and now we've got the other Jason
Williams this conversation is a long one
but I think that we've got some pretty
interesting topics covered so appreciate
you guys listening to this and thank you
so much for coming and doing this Jason
yeah it's my pleasure
it's good to be here Jason and I dressed
up when Mark was here we had on a
button-down and looked the part and now
when Jason's here I've got a t-shirt on
and so does Jason so perfect yeah but
you called me beforehand and told me to
wear a t-shirt yeah because I'm also in
charge of the Wardrobe on the podcast
all right
so Jason I have known each other for a
really long time at this point let's go
through your background first so people
who don't know you can get a sense of it
yeah so I'm from New York originally
Queens and moved to Florida so I you
were born in Florida right in Miami and
Hollywood Miami Hollywood Florida so I
was on the East Coast and Stuart went to
high school there then ended up coming
back to North Carolina to go to school
trained as a physician assistant they
started that program while I was at
Methodist I played soccer and football
there then got accepted to Yale and to
do a surgical residency as a physician
assistant while I was at Yale came up
with the idea for fast med all right
before we get into fast med explain the
difference between a physician assistant
and a doctor yeah yeah so think of a
physician assistant as someone who goes
to school gets his bachelor's degree
pre-med then does another two years so
it's it was born out of Naval corpsman
who were in Vietnam actually these guys
came back from the war and couldn't
transition into civilian work
so at Duke University they created this
program to bring these naval corpsman
into civilian practice as physician
assistants and so these guys have
tremendous capacity to diagnose and
treat do all kinds of procedures really
manual dexterity a lot of manual
dexterity and they created physician
assistant school so that's my training I
wasn't in the military as you were but I
actually trained at Womack Army Medical
Center because Methodists didn't have a
hospital at that time so all of my
training was at Fort Bragg in
Fayetteville North Carolina
very very cool so you're there and you
come up with this wild-ass idea while
you're at Yale did a surgical residency
maybe explain a little bit about what
the initial idea was that eventually
became fast med yeah so while I was
doing that surgical residency
the surgical team at Yale is responsible
to take care of trauma so anytime
there's any type of surgical trauma that
comes into the emergency room the
surgical team is called to the emergency
room to assess the patient what I was
realizing through that experience was a
number of things the physicians and
nurses at what I thought was one of the
most prestigious hospitals in the
country possibly the world were pissed
off angry and I didn't understand that
my whole life I had you know focused and
prepared for this really important
transition into practice of medicine and
you know it almost felt like like
volunteer or you know like you're
contributing something really big to
society and I was really confused
by the way patients were interfacing
with the physicians and nursing staff in
the way the nurses and physicians were
interfacing with the patients it just
seemed like everyone was just really
angry and confused and and it left a big
impression on me I thought it could be
done better I thought that customer
service was totally non-existent in
health care the whole institution was
built to
be lined up for the physicians so it was
on their schedule on their time on their
availability and the patients were just
subjected to cruelty all right
so came up with the idea to develop a
retail oriented medical practice that
would do eighty percent of what you'd
find in a emergency room so it would
take care of all the non life
threatening but urgent scenarios that
you would potentially have and what type
of situations are those right so it
could be broken bones lacerations colds
coughs pneumonia asthma attacks allergic
reactions so it's a lot of complicated
stuff that these naval corpsman were
trained to do like right in the sweet
spot of a physician assistant so I knew
I could do that stuff using allied
health care professionals and nurse
practitioners and physician assistants
and do it at one-tenth the cost if I
brought it into a retail center 3,000 to
5,000 square foot footprint with 80% of
the capabilities of a big-box emergency
department so basically the initial idea
is you can provide better customer
service more efficient and kind of
convenient location and then from a cost
structure standpoint because you don't
have the physician who has the big
salary and kind of all the costs
associated with it and you're using the
physician's assistant and the nurse
practitioner you bring down that cost
structure pretty dramatically and I'm
guessing that you pass some of that on
to the patient as well yeah I mean it
was one-tenth the cost
so everybody's saving you know if you
don't have insurance you're getting
access to care and if you have insurance
those benefits are passed on to the
insurer right they're getting the big
savings so they're not getting a 10x
cost so it was very good this is you
know I socialized it to my professors
while I was at Yale they're like you
know good ideas are hard to come by you
should probably do that so literally
called my mother told her I was dropping
out moved back to North Carolina I
bought a post office so I want to talk
about the post office
you know your young guy who's got this
idea you kind of had already jumped
right and at good school you know you
want to go do this but getting a
business started in this field in health
care it's not like building a software
company right so in the software world
if you've got an internet connection you
got a computer you got some skills you
can literally spin up a server you could
build a website you can kind of go to
town right from your couch you can't do
that when you want to build a retail
healthcare clinic you have to go get a
physical location there's licensing
there's kind of regulation there their
staff and marketing etc maybe just
describe you know one how'd you pick
where you were gonna get the first
location and then I know the story but
let's go through the how you acquire at
the post office
yeah so I think what you're describing
are like a set light businesses you know
this is an asset heavy business highly
regulated business and even though we
use technology so there's lots of tech
in healthcare this is pre electronic
medical record so when I started we were
using paper medical records paper
systems paper claims I go out to First
Citizens Bank I you know I'm 23 years
old and convinced them to lend me just
enough money to go to an auction to buy
a post office in this town called Hope
Mills North Carolina I picked the post
office because it was like the city
center right it was away from the
hospital the institutional kind of
aggregated area where you'd have found
typically medical offices this was near
your Starbucks your coffee shop where
you went to the grocery store post
office etc that was the general thesis
at first so I won the post office at
auction bootstrapped it with some
friends hired a medical director because
at that time physician assistants still
needed oversight right it's a dependent
practice it's not an independent
practice so you have to work as part of
a healthcare team again that's what made
it so attractive to me you know you're
building a healthcare team
that coordinated care and communication
we could leverage and
be far better than your primary care
doctor in the same location who's not
being challenged by some smart kids who
are practicing alongside of them does
that make sense absolutely yeah so first
practice I start early 2001 then we deal
with 911 we go through that I learn a
lot during that time the business and
the practice is super successful you see
if you look back over the decade that I
ran that that health care is
economically insulated from a lot of the
things that you historically have to
deal with with other businesses when you
deal with economic collapse I mean if
you think about from 2000 to 2015 while
I was part of a fast med we went through
a lot as a country and our trajectory as
a business was up and to the right well
it also you know the acquisition of that
first property right I think one of the
things we've talked about a lot is this
idea of like the banks are likely to
lend money to people who don't need it
and when people need money they're
unlikely to lend the money and so being
a young kid with how to track record
right and kind of just an idea the
options of financing a business I think
when you have that asset heavy type
business there's not a lot of venture
capital right that's available and even
back in 2010 one that wasn't a very
popular way to finance businesses
outside of maybe the Silicon Valley area
and so you have to look at these other
financing mechanisms right you have to
go to banks you have to go to private
investors that are kind of less
sophisticated and venture capital and
more in a private equity model and so
it's kudos to you that you even got it
done right let alone was able to kind of
scale that over time yeah pump my
accountant would tell you that I wasn't
in the urgent care business I was a real
estate developer because that's really
the way that we got the banks to lend
the money they weren't banking my my
early-stage venture into owning urgent
care they were lending me money to buy a
post office yet right so we were
leveraging that property at first
that using you know financing to buy an
asset build it into a revenue generating
model and I quickly learn that you can
use this levered real estate thesis over
and over again
I never made one mortgage payment
personally the businesses float these
these mortgages and you know at the end
of this story at a hundred and twenty
three locations across the country so
what I want to talk about is how do we
go from the first post office to 123
right what was the kind of in-between
story of I think a lot of people when
they get when they build a successful
business people want to know what's the
origin story and they want to know what
was the outcome but that middle part I
think for most businesses is where a lot
of the meet happens right in execution
and then obviously with your story
there's multiple transactions and kind
of a bunch of stuff that happened in
there but maybe just walk us from okay
you start the first one its successful
you see that the model works kind of
where do you go from there yeah so we
open the first urging here in Hope Mills
North Carolina I'm working nights in the
emergency room still you know because
you're paying yourself last you know and
I'd like to talk at some point about you
know how I how I feel about
entrepreneurship self-employment being a
business owner how you deal with
investments I think that's interesting
it's something that you know I was able
to confirm through just reading as I've
gotten older and like you pick up books
Robert Kiyosaki's Rich Dad Poor Dad cash
flow quadrants my fastings no but I'll
tell you that you know that's the the
greatest thing that can happen to you is
you can try something you can you can
test a thesis it seems to be working for
you and then smart people confirm that
you know so that confirmation just
hardens your conviction and then you
just keep going and that's really what
happened with fast med right we opened
up the first Urgent Care I'm recruiting
my friends my other PA buddies from
around the the country hiring physicians
working nights in the emergency
department open up my second office open
up my third office and actually take
quite a bit of time I'm only opening up
one office a year at first oh really
yeah I was like from 2001 to 2009 I
probably had 10 locations okay 10
locations 74 employees most of them are
ancillary staff physicians physician
assistants but we have a nice business
all located in North Carolina and in
2010 October 2010 we complete our first
transaction for outside capital with a
small venture group called confessed
capital out of Palm Beach Florida and so
when you do that what was the thought
process in terms of taking outside
capital that kind of scale faster or
yeah that's that's it it was there was a
lot of interesting things happening in
the US healthcare system at that time
you had the election of President Obama
I was looking at universal health care
as being something that was highly
likely to be passed and what would that
mean to us health care would access go
down would access go up who would be the
gatekeepers of health care would it be
the insurance companies or the primary
care physicians and then how did fast
med play into the overall landscape
because it was it was unbelievable to me
at 23 and the group that I had working
with me that we could go into any town
in North Carolina to start and open up
infrastructure healthcare infrastructure
you would think you couldn't do that
it would be like the privatizing of of
fire departments you know you just don't
see that happening I but we were able to
pull that off quite dramatically and we
tested that in North Carolina and and
then into multiple states got it and so
you take the user transaction with comm
vest and then eventually you end up
doing something with a Blue Cross Blue
Shield maybe talk a little bit about the
second transaction that kind of what
happened there and it was somewhat
groundbreaking in the healthcare
industry yeah so we we completed the
transaction with comm best in 2010
October used that capital to like
blitzscale so really fast growth
nine ten offices October 2010 74
employees 2015 14 hundred employees 123
locations across the country so I was
hiring over 300 people a year and just
managing crazy growth in 2012 this this
was an important moment for us it was
the first time in u.s. health care that
a major payer had invested in the
provider side of healthcare and if you
step back for a second and you let that
kind of wash over you think of the
competitive nature and the ethical
questions you'd have that your payer the
insurance company owns the provider of
the healthcare where are the incentives
is there alignment are they cost
conscious and making decisions based off
of their fiduciary responsibilities to
drive profit or are they truly spending
money to provide you with the highest
and best health care spar you know
sparing and and not contemplating profit
what was the answer it was doing the
right thing you know and I can tell you
while I was there at fast med the
insurance company did a great job of
blinding us to who were those who had
Blue Cross Blue Shield but allowed us to
develop patient steerage campaigns to
help guide decision making because
that's part of what was wrong with
healthcare and what I recognized in 2001
when I dropped out of Yale the reason
everyone was so pissed off is because
people were in the wrong place right
you're at Yale at 8:00 p.m. with a
toothache in the emergency room of
course the emergency room physician is
going to be like why are you here but
the patient's like my doctors not open
where am I supposed to go and this thing
hurts
I need antibiotics and pain medicine to
make sense yep so all I wanted to do is
create an option for them between the
hospital emergency room and their
primary care physician who was closed he
was not optimized for urgent or
NEADS right it was all scheduled
appointments well and the kind of family
physician or you know whatever that role
is it's really more of a lifestyle type
thing because they're dependent on the
doctor right if the doctor is not there
the physicians not there there's not a
lot of work getting done right and so
you know we've talked at length between
you and I about there's no work getting
done really there's there's refills and
reschedule but there's no decision maker
there there's no decision-making there
so they're chokepoint on the business
right and so it's super unscalable
because if you don't see the physician
you don't go there right the only reason
to go is to actually see the physician
and have them look at you and have them
make the decision and make obviously can
only see so many patients per day and
then at some point they want to go home
to their families etc and so that kind
of leaves open the opportunity for for
something like fast med and it's it's a
little worse than that - for the primary
care physician because they have
admission responsibilities so they're
also rounding in the hospital so and
then to create new revenue opportunities
some of them will take on nursing home
responsibilities so all of that provides
less access for the patient so those
were the things that we knew we could
disrupt in 2001 now you have the advent
of hospitalists so the primary care
physician doesn't necessarily have to
round on you when you go into the
hospital I don't know if that's
necessarily the greatest thing though
right you want your primary care
physician to see you and take care of
you and be the coordinator of care but
now you have these patient care teams
that you hope are communicating in the
most efficient transparent of ways so as
you're building the business obviously
you get to 14-under employees there's a
lot of employees now and then you've f1
23 locations you got this huge business
multi states and again that this
multi-state is important because it's a
highly regulated business right so not
only you're dealing with kind of federal
healthcare rules and regulations but
also at the state level they've got the
insurance and and all these different
things going on
and at the same time you mentioned
earlier not only building the business
you're actually executing a real estate
acquisition effort as well right because
the the model here is not to hey I'm
gonna go set up my practice in a we work
right where I just walk in you know sign
a piece of paper and I've got a
one-month lease you actually have to go
and acquire physical infrastructure so
you got to get land in a building and
then you've got to build that out to
ensure that it can facilitate the work
that you want to do inside of that
building for health care so not only
just you know hey are there check out
rooms are there beds or all that kind of
stuff but also it has to meet certain
specific requirements from other
regulators and the your own business
right so you kind of have these dual
businesses or business lines that are
being built one is a real estate
acquisition one is actually building the
business maybe talk a little bit about
balancing those two responsibilities and
kind of how you thought about where to
put your time versus maybe hiring others
to handle some of it yeah I think the
the real estate acquisition component is
super critical so I spent a lot of time
on that and we built a pretty
sophisticated cloud mapping technology
we used I don't even know if you guys
still use Google Earth at all yeah it's
around all right but it was actually a
pretty cool tool when it first came out
because you could look at alike view
right but you could load all of these
different demographic things and
indicators and and create a model that
could give you a idea of a zip codes
potential to place one of our centers so
we had about 40 unique demographic
indicators that we used and they were
peculiar they had to do with access
line-of-sight traffic patterns traffic
count population sophistication of the
population the socio-economic situations
in the population and on and on and on
I can go on there we felt really smart
all it showed me was Blockbuster video
stores and at the same time and I was
scaling a business blockbuster of what's
going out of business so all we did was
go out and pre les blockbuster
Oh stores so Jason started out buying a
post office and then he basically I
think he became one of if not the
largest acquire of bought bought a big
infrastructure yeah we literally started
a program inside fast me that was called
warehousing so before the Blockbuster
video store would go out of business I
would go to the owner of these blocks of
blockbusters and say I'm going to pre
lease your store I'm gonna pay you right
now nine dollars a square foot something
like that and I want the first option on
the store once it closes down so we had
all kinds of real estate tied up a huge
growth plan set up and a huge market I
mean I was doing 1.5 million patients a
year so just to give you a sense of what
that means a large a large emergency
department will do 45,000 80,000 patient
visits a year one hospital emergency
room we were doing 1.5 million patient
visits a year so the in terms of
allocation of my time huge portion of it
was citing new sites for growth the
other one was culture you know and
that's something that you and I don't
really spend a lot of time on I don't
think we've ever really talked about the
importance of culture but for me holding
together the growth and maintaining the
integrity of the practice right we're in
the practice of health care I don't
think that practicing health care and
being profitable have to be mutually
exclusive
I ripped off a quote from of cash what
I'm blanking on it but I'll give you the
quote essentially says profit should be
your first social responsibility right
if profits your first social
responsibility then you can do all the
other things that you want to do Peter
Drucker its Peter Drucker essentially
yeah so you have to have money and then
you can give all your money away if you
want but you can't be the reverse now
can't be the reverse well it's also this
idea
yeah if you go back to your example at
Yale where everyone's pissed off right
and the quality of the care suffers the
experience suffers it's kind of the
people you interact with where we've all
gone to some kind of service provider
whether it's healthcare or something
else and the person doesn't want to be
there right and you're just like man
this sucks
I think I know this person I want to be
here I feel like a burden on them that's
fine if it's a lawyer or something like
that it's completely different when
you're coming in here the one with a
toothache right or the gunshot wound or
you know whatever it is and so I think
that your idea around culture is really
important
it probably trickled down into the
customer experience a pop I literally
fought every day to maintain the empathy
and that connectedness between you know
our staff and the patients I mean your
point is exactly that it's what was
lacking in my experience in 2001 where
the hospital's treated people as
patients and we were treating patients
as customers so it's really a simple
nuance a simple transition but just if
you want if you if you want to create a
premium customer experience well what do
you do in healthcare to do that your
healthcare establishment doesn't feel
it's sterile but it doesn't feel sterile
it may feel more like your community
coffee shop you know you have technology
there and you use it but maybe it's not
the showcase
maybe there's different seating
different aesthetics you know those are
the things that that we've really worked
hard on for sure all right so you built
this thing into an absolute beast it's
what like the second largest at that
time a retail chain of urgent care
facilities now and then a Bri comes
along maybe talk a little bit about who
a Bri is and kind of how that happened
yeah so a breeze a boston-based private
equity firm we ran a process just like
we did in 2010 and 2012
they gave me an opportunity to have a
complete exit which was interesting and
scary you know this was my whole life's
work as an adult I mean I started the
company at 25 years old so
exit was was pretty dramatic but it was
it was a great event for myself and for
investors was nearly half a billion
dollar exit and now it's a breeze you
know it's really wild drew it up guys
yeah yeah I mean good luck yeah but so
I'm blocked out of health care for ten
years so I can't do anything non
appointment-based and I had been doing
some angel investing before my exit and
thinking about things I wanted to do
next really interested in biochemistry
physics
I've written some patents in robotics
like jumping robots I was inspired
watching a guy on the side of the road
work with a reciprocating tamper do you
know what that is that's the actual like
it looks almost like a jackhammer yeah
that you hold and it smashes the ground
right ides it out right I built those
that are automated so you don't have to
hold them which is pretty gonna be
pretty interesting right so to do that
you have to have accelerometers that if
you ever seen them kick that DARPA like
robotic cow yeah and it won't fall over
and that's the same that's the stuff
that I've worked on so Britain patents
and that issued and also in like thermal
D manufacturing after you sell the
business and you sign the papers
kind of money all gets wired everything
the next day what are you thinking well
I think you'd gone to work every day for
15 years and worked your ass off like I
do you just say like this is cool or are
you sad or like what's the feeling well
it actually happened on a Thursday okay
so I was negotiating what I may do going
forward with the acquire a Bri and with
fast med and we couldn't really come to
terms like it wasn't gonna be big enough
for me okay so on a Thursday they told
me I could have a complete exit and I
moved out of my office on Saturday
okay and I started my next startup on
Monday alright and so as you do that
let's talk a little bit about PR TI and
kind of what that is and how you got
involved and kind of where you guys are
today yeah so I had a number of
early-stage venture businesses that I
had been investing in starting in 2014
let's call it writing checks like
hundred thousand two hundred fifty
thousand dollar checks and trying to
help from the periphery one of those
investments I made in 2014 was PRT I
it's a really interesting company was
founded by this Italian inventor named
Franco Feeny and Franco Feeny had
exposure to the waste industry so this
has every Italian yeah why not right so
this this Italian family has a waste
business started in 1974 called a'dreea
dill they invested in Franco Feeny's
technology they spent about 12 million
euro to take it through three iterations
of of like form factor and then idled
that technology so it came to this group
that I invested in is attention and they
wanted to domesticate it move it to the
United States and potentially roll it
out across the country you know the
group were real estate developers and a
guy who had renovated Bennigan's I don't
even know if Bennigan's still exists
it's around Applebee's okay so did this
group wanted to build an international
waste management business that used a
proprietary piece of technology to to to
process synthetic polymers right we're
laughing because we know them and the
courage and also the delusion it takes
to say I can do that is frankly the
people that you want to be around right
but also having people that are
pragmatic
realistic enough to understand we can do
this but we can go faster and be more
effective if maybe we bring more and
more people in that have the scientific
backgrounds the technology backgrounds
etc to accomplish it yeah I mean and
especially a business we we we talk
about a set light businesses this is a
superacid heavy business jason's two for
two on the asset heavy businesses yeah i
mean it was it was something else so i
made an investment i joined their board
and then I told them look I'm gonna
leave fast med June of 2015
I'll come on is the CEO run the business
raise the capital will go I mean and
they're like what are you what do you
want to do I said I'm going to package
the plant that's an arm in Italy I'm
gonna put it in comics containers I'm
gonna ship it to some land that will buy
a 15 miles from my house in Raleigh and
we'll build this waste-to-energy oil
refinery there and and just go from the
ground up all right so hold on before we
get into shipping this let's talk about
how the business works right so when you
say waste-to-energy there's kind of
three separate components to the
business right there's a front-end kind
of a scientific process and then there's
that the outputs walk us through kind of
those three different sections of the
business or kind of bodies at work yes
so here in North America there are 300
million used car tires a year that need
to be disposed of and traditionally you
either shred bury or burn those tires
because tires are built to last they're
built to not fall apart so there's no
real smart way to dispose of them you've
even heard people I think it was in
Florida where they they started to
construct reefs underwater with these
with these tires they chained them
together and put them at the bottom of
the ocean what they found were giant
dead reefs so they've now had to pull
those tires up PRT I and Franco Feeny
developed a way to heat a tire a tire is
a semi solid it has some natural rubber
components some steel some fabric
associated with it and a lot of oil
you'll be surprised at the amount of oil
that's in a tire
but he developed a way to thoughtfully
break that apart and capture those
constituent parts that the tire was made
of so you have a huge total available
market of 300 million tires a year that
need to be disposed of a legacy business
that is [ __ ] like but the total
dinosaur shredding burying burning you
have a technology solution that's
thoughtful environmentally friendly
scalable super interesting to me super
interesting to me they'll pay me to take
the tires so it's kind of an
infrastructure play on the front end
where you're just a waste management
business so just to summarize this the
tires are getting disposed of already
right they're used there they're coming
out of wherever and they're gonna get
thrown away or destroyed the destruction
use described is actually really bad for
the environment or energy intensity yeah
yeah and so you know as we've talked
about this the things that have caught
my attention is they throw them in the
ocean they bury them in landfills they
chop them up and they put them on the
playground for children little chips of
rubber right a soccer field yeah I mean
always crazy stuff that's going on and
you had a technology that could
essentially break the tire down using
this thermal D manufacturing process
that we'll get into but the first
property that I solve is basically where
do we get the tires from right I think
that's what you're talking about now
where not only can get the tires but
they'll actually pay you to take the
tires so kind of describe why they're
paying you to take them versus you know
you have to pay for basically the
supplies of your business yes so most if
not all municipal governments and
counties will allow you to bring a used
tire to a landfill and they'll take it
for free as a service as a taxpaying
service but then that landfill a
municipality has to pay to have it
disposed of so there's a third party
that's coming to transport pick up and
dispose of of those tires so that's
typically a landfill a mono fill or a
shredding company that's making
pelletized rubber or or
shredding and burying does that make
sense yep and then that's really it it's
it's nothing more than that got it so so
they will actually pay you to take the
tires bring them to the plant and for
those that are listening the plant is an
industrial plant right I mean it's what
six seven acres of 10 acres of land
there are huge concrete bays with you
know piled high with tires and there are
big metal reactors right they kind of
look like cylindrical [ __ ] tubes if you
will and then there's warehouse space
right that has kind of offices and all
kinds of stuff in there so this is a
very kind of metal as a heavy but very
industrial type business very very
different than sitting on your couch
writing software but as you figure out
okay we can get paid to take these tires
what happens to the tire once you bring
it on-site well one of the things that
we found as we started to scale was that
there was a number of tires that were
coming out of the manufacturing site
that were blemished that weren't road
worthy and needed to be thoughtfully
disposed of and actually you know you
had to provide a certificate of
destruction to make absolutely sure they
didn't get back on the road and your
guys right I mean there was something
wrong with the tire I mean it just came
off of the the manufacturing line and it
was messed up and you'd be surprised at
the the tolerance of a loss yield here
it's about eight to ten percent so a
typical Bridgestone plant makes 30,000
tires a day 30,000 tires a day with a
10% loss yield so what we calculated was
32 million additional tires a year are
these blemished tires that need to be
disposed of I went directly to the tire
manufacturer and contracted with them so
I don't even at this point deal with the
municipal waste the 300 million tires
all I'm disposing of our brand-new tires
they're coming out of the tire
manufacturers so these blemished tires
have been going on for a while right
there's been this kind of lost yield
that business is very sketchy in the
disposal of these tires right so the
tires come off the manufacturing line
they in many cases look like good tires
right there's some you can tell you
can't tell what's wrong with them
there's some small blemish and they are
handed over to somebody to destroy them
and so you said before that before
they're loaded on a truck a guy takes a
knife and slashes the sidewall
historically before I got there they
would not always slash all the sidewalls
so there was another business going on
where you could resell those tires it's
a huge business so part of that waste
disposal in the tire business is a
reselling business where they find
identify pearls like if you were a
golfer you know you're playing golf but
you're always kind of looking around for
you know lost balls that's what these
guys were doing they were finding like
pearls like and reselling these tires
and you know we know that it could be a
pretty big component of these tire
disposal companies revenue we don't do
any reselling and and what we've been
able to do by being present in the
market is absolutely certify that these
tires are being destroyed they're not on
the road there's a dangerous yeah it
won't end it's because what they're
essentially doing is they're trying to
find tires that oh maybe they don't meet
the exact specification but they're good
enough they turn around they basically
they don't know what's wrong with the
tire I'm just telling you some random
guy whose responsibility is to load the
tire on the truck is deciding to not
slash the sidewall because he's getting
a brown bag he's getting paid to do that
and then the guys were unloading the
tires are looking for the pearls right
there saying sidewall slash sidewall
slash sidewall / good tire they put it
to the side put it to the side that tire
ends up at the used done the cool side
to the side to the side right because
think about how many when I say 300
million tires a year you have to put
things in perspective
I can only process and my plant runs 25
days a month you know all year 24 hours
a day
we process 1.5 million pounds of tires a
month
1.5 million pounds each tires 28 pounds
so I may be of round a million tires
mm-hm
you know it's not a lot yeah it's not a
lot well and I bring you this up because
one yeah these are the little nooks and
crannies of businesses where I think
people don't really understand some of
the stuff that goes on but too is a you
know one of the things that you and I
have really spent a lot of time talking
about you know as we've invested is
finding businesses where people kind of
just do the right thing and when they do
the right thing which you actually end
up doing is one you set yourself up to
be a sustainable business right you kind
of don't have cobwebs in the corner that
maybe one day can get exposed but to is
you actually can create market dynamics
and market forces that put a lot of
pressure on your competitors right and
so when the manufacturers understand hey
these guys are not gonna play this game
of reselling and not slashing the
sidewalls and doing all of this there's
a little bit more trust and confidence
that hey we should make sure that they
get every tire that they can possibly
take versus you know we know some shady
stuff's going on over here we can't
necessarily stop it but we're not happy
about it and it's dangerous right
people's lives are at risk if they're
driving down the street with a tire that
is doesn't meet the specifications
necessary now it's so true and and most
if not all of the CEOs of these tire
manufacturers have self mandated zero
landfill policies so they do not want
those tires coming out of their their
plant ending up in a landfill so it's
it's super important to align with a
company like PRT I that has this thermal
D manufacturing technology and we're
able to recover the tire it's a green
story and if you if you start to
contemplate the carbon footprint the
effect of of eliminating the waste
stream and re re-establishing the
constituent components of a tire back
into the market you really are doing
something positive for sure let's dig
into the technology how thermo d
manufacturing big words essentially
means that you're going to use a high
degree of heat to burn the tire and now
I get down he does didn't like that he
does
so the the technology of pyrolysis so
pyrolysis is a reaction in the absence
of oxygen and that's what everyone's
tried to do with tires for the last 40
years so it's not a new technology
you're essentially taking some type of
horizontally oriented vessel you're
filling it with tires chipped tyre so
you've shredded them and you've taken
the steel out of them and then you're
externally heating that vessel and
you're rotating it so think of a
rotisserie like a chicken rotisserie
you're eliminating the oxygen inside of
it right so you're not lighting anything
on fire inside you're just heating it
but you're heating it externally got it
all right so zero oxygen environment
heating it externally and you're rolling
it you're using an auger inside of that
horizontally oriented cylinder and
you're driving the volatiles and the
materials that your D manufacturing or
essentially breaking breaking down and
you're pushing them out of the vessel so
it's a long process that requires a lot
of external energy and usually breaks
that's why it hasn't worked historically
if they've tried it when oil is $100 a
barrel it didn't work they tried it when
oils $27 a barrel didn't work you know
it's highly dependent on the tipping fee
so if you're if you're coming into this
market you think well how do I disrupt
it if I can build a business that can
work on zero front end so even though
they're gonna pay me to take the tire if
I'm not really dependent on that front
end I can disrupt them because they
don't have a lot of alternatives right
what you mean there's basically although
they're willing to pay me to take the
tires if I can build a business that is
so profitable and sustainable that I can
tell them I'll take the tires for free
then you get all the tires and pump when
I had that epiphany like this is 2014
and that's why I was ready to leave fast
med I was like holy crap man these guys
are gonna pay me to take tires and I'm
literally sitting on an energy company I
never looked at PRT I as a waste
disposal company I was watching like
Tesla Tesla isn't to me he's not a car
company it's a battery technology
company why
by SolarCity because he needed a place
to actually make power right
why is he developing battery tech and
that the home device is because he needs
storage right so here you go you've got
solar energy you can make power you've
got battery tech I can store it I can
transact it into the grid that's right
he's got a comprehensive energy thesis
PRT and it's a privatized
somewhat decentralized energy
infrastructure that he's building it's
it's huge think about that historically
you have to interface with whatever
power company you're dealing with
they're gonna tell you the rates you're
a price taker you don't have a choice if
you want to buy alternative energy
you're not really buying it he's
building something quite interesting and
I looked at PRT I the same way
I've got tires to me it's a battery it's
a stored power source they're gonna pay
me to take it so I don't really have an
input cost there I have a technology
that's quite different than what I just
described to you with pyrolysis and I'll
explain to you how the tech works and I
can make power I can sell it to the grid
or do something even more interesting so
before we get into the tech the input is
tires into the technology the output is
carbon steel sin gas and oil right yep
and you're able to look at those
commodities sell some of them as
commodities some of them you can do
certain things to manipulate them into
energies where you're saying basically
get energy out of the back end how do
you go from a tire to those four outputs
on the back end of that technology right
so when I explained pyrolysis to you I
talked about the fact that it was a very
labor intensive and very cost
inefficient process where you have to
use a lot of external energy to heat
this what we're doing with our
technology is we have a vertically
oriented chamber not a horizontally
oriented chamber so the vertical
orientation allows for gravity to affect
the simple machine what I do is I load
whole car tires into the
vertically oriented cylinder so they're
not chipped
there's no pre-processing or pre
handling as you know because you've been
out at the site we grab the tires we
take whole car tires and we fill the the
processing tower with them it's about
six thousand pounds of whole tires I
closed the lid mechanically and then I
pull a vacuum on it so we have vacuum
pumps that are evacuating the atmosphere
out of the chamber then I insert a torch
into the bottom of of the processing
tower and there's thermal concrete I
don't know if any of you barbecue like
use a green egg barbecue but the reason
it gets so hot is because the thermal
concrete won't let the heat escape it's
actually all driven up through the food
we do the exact same thing so I use a
super hot torch for 20 minutes in the
bottom of the processing tower and I
heat the tires that are down there
violently for 20 minutes and I turn them
into coal so superheated coal and steel
at the bottom after 20 minutes I extract
that torch and then this is where the
interesting tech happens we use what
I'll call a catalyst which is just
atmosphere the atmosphere is 19 percent
oxygen in it I'm pulling oxygen over hot
coals and then radiating that heat up a
stack of whole tires and I'm controlling
the temperature zones up that 40-foot
stack so it's just a time and
temperature process a tires a semi solid
it turns into a vapor very quickly so
you just change the phase and our
process takes about 10 hours to change
6,000 pounds of tires from semi solid
into liquids and gases got it and with
only 20 minutes of energy input 10 hours
of energy output each processing tower
creates 0.23 megawatts of power it's
crazy
it's wild so then when you daisy chain
these reactors together you know when
our model is is to have 16 you're
talking about making like 6-7 megawatts
of base power that they paid me
take the input and well it and to me the
part here that is so interesting is we
talked a lot about these asset heavy
businesses right this industrial type
business there's a lot of technology
that goes on in this right so for those
that have never been to an industrial
site or seen one of these businesses
when you walk in there are screens
everywhere there's a control room right
that the that the towers themselves that
torch all of this is automated in
various ways to really allow for a
relatively small team in terms of
headcount to manage what ends up being
tens of thousands if not hundreds of
thousands of pounds every single day
being taken from that semi-solid
into the the gas and the vapors yeah I
mean we 90 98 percent of the process is
automated so the entrance exit of those
torches the controls we have
programmable logic controllers you know
that's where my coding experience came
in so you know we we wrote all of that
code to to automate the process and the
only thing that's manual at this point
is the unloading of the tires the
discharge of the material and then we've
got a pretty crude oil refinery on site
too and you were talking about the
assets it really is a waste receiving
component on the front the technology
that processes the tires in the middle
steel sorting carbon sorting and oil
refining alright so I want to pause on
prsti for second we'll come back to this
for the fun part I want to jump to how
you and I met and kind of the early days
of Full Tilt and then it will become
obvious why I want to pause on the PRT a
conversation we'll come back to that but
just your your memory of how we met kind
of some of the early conversations then
why we decided to to start Full Tilt
which was the first thing that we did
together yeah so I've made a few
investments in companies that overlapped
with Mark Cuban and a few people that we
we know one of them was
undercover colors it was a date-rape
technology that came out and see state
it was initially supposed to be a nail
polish that detected six different
typical types of date-rape drugs i also
invested in a company called panda
health it was in Africa in Kenya that
Mark Cuban was attempting to invest in
and we had a co like a friend a mutual
friend that was working in his firm that
introduced us I think you had just just
left Facebook and was and left snap so
you left Facebook then you're at snap
and you were moving back to Raleigh I
live in Raleigh North Carolina and they
said look really interesting guy you
should meet I think you and I met at
morning Times downtown Raleigh for 30
minutes we had planned just to meet up
we ended up spending three hours or so
together it was really since wife was
called say where are you let's go please
polina couple goals so yeah so we we we
literally just hit it off you wanted to
start like a hundred million dollar fund
i hey why don't we when we try to raise
like you know ten million and we decided
to create full-tilt it really came out
of like almost our first meetings wild
so I'm gonna tell two stories one was in
the first meeting when we were talking
[Music]
to strap there was two strategies that
we discuss right one was go raise a
larger venture capital fund mainly from
family offices and institutions or raise
a smaller more micro VC fund and jason
said to me i'm the king of the hundred
thousand dollar check and I'll never
forget this guy said to him what the
hell does that mean and he explained to
me that the you know kind of the
challenges when you're whale hunting and
the time it takes versus being much more
optimized on look just get started build
the momentum and really gets kind of
things going and it's starting to
establish that track record which is
obviously what we ended up doing and so
the second story is the first meeting
was at the this bar and went very well
we got hit it off
and adjacent says to me let's meet up
again said alright where you gonna meet
and he says to me want you coming out to
the PRT I plant and I've only I said
okay and he said but I'm gonna need you
to help me with some stuff and and I
don't know the exact conversation but
it's basically like you're not coming
here to sit in a conference room so just
be prepared okay that's fine
and when I showed up at PRT I the car
tires actually show up in 18-wheelers
and so they pack I don't know how many
time in a thousand okay so a thousand
tires into an 18-wheeler and they're
woven very tightly it's not just thrown
in there they're systematically woven
into a solution super efficient and the
only way to get them out as of right now
is for somebody to jump in the back the
only way to get them out there's no way
you can grab them with some mechanical
device you'd blow the sides out of the
trailer each other so you got it puts a
human in and literally grab each tire
one by one and throw it out of the
18-wheeler which when you're near the
when it's full and you're near the edge
doesn't sound like that big of a deal
because you kind of just grab it and
toss it well though they're 28 pounds
each and there's a thousand of them but
as you get deeper and deeper into the
18-wheeler eighteen wheelers are pretty
far fifty thirty feet and so you've got
to literally grab the tire off the stack
and then walk it to the end and then
throw it over a wall Road over a wall
into the bay where they sit and so the
second meeting Jason I ever had was in
the middle of the summer there was July
in North Carolina heat in the back of an
18-wheeler tossing a thousand tires out
of this thing into the bay while we
discussed should we build an investment
firm heard not and at the end I remember
us being like well we're both willing to
do this we've probably got a good shot
at getting along and this might be
something that we should go pursue
together yeah man I'll tell you it mean
it meant a lot to me that you came out
to do that because that's the kind of
CEO I am and that's the kind of person I
am like I don't want anything for free
and I don't I typically have to put my
hands on things to truly understand them
and you even you probably have seen that
in the way I invest when we when we do
something together like I try to buy the
product I try to use it like you know I
think somebody asks in your Twitter feed
has he run in a full no
of course I'm running a full note is a
dumb question run a full note and I
think that part of it was when we were
there it's not just hey you know we're
doing physical work to do this and by
the way right I Jason and I both have
done plenty of physical work in our life
it sucks right is the best way to put it
just that you know just absolutely sucks
but it was the fact that you were
running the company you had plenty of
employees there that could have been
doing that work but you said you know
look there's better use of these
employees time when it comes to some of
the more technical stuff or the
mechanical stuff this is just a pure
grunt work type exercise I'll go do it
right because I can free up my employees
that go do more important things
also pump when I told you about culture
typically the hard parts in a business
executives avoid they they don't like
the conflict they don't like the the
points that hurt I tend to go there to
humanize them and to establish that's my
base you know so the front end of the
business the manual part unloading of
the trucks and July of North Carolina
and the heat I go out there and I do
that because it is hard it sets the tone
that's it it sets the tone everyone else
is like oh I can't complain that dudes
over there and if he's willing to do
that not only do I need to do that I got
to do everything else and I require a
lot of time to think anyway so spending
an hour unloading a truck like that
helps the business it helps me it gets
me out of the office you know
anyway it's just important for you
mathematicians at home a thousand tires
in an hour nobody is exactly doing it at
a slow pace so we decide we're going to
go build full-tilt and the whole idea is
basically to create a early stage
investment firm and in hindsight I don't
think any of this was intentional but
correct me if you had some master plan
but in hindsight looking back
[Music]
there's a lot of things that we did that
I think were counterintuitive to people
the first being we didn't have a website
for I think a year it was the entire
time do we now I well the very first
investment from we're and I think we
finally got a website I mean you call it
a website it was a wordpress landing
page yeah I don't think that's a website
as people were getting mad that there
was no URL or anything and then the
second thing was we didn't have an
office we used to work out of a
Starbucks right and I bring those up
because it's always been what's the
actual most important thing right not
what's the things that make us feel
important or what are the things that
everyone else is doing so we feel like
we need to do it but it from very early
on has always been what is actually the
most important thing to get done today
to help build this business and I don't
think there's a lot of people who do
that but but across multiple businesses
that you've build right and the ones we
built together I think that's always
been one of these themes that's really
important pump we've seen those
businesses that we've invested in that
have have thought that those were
mandatory requirements like having
palatial office space and and comforts
that you would typically see in the
world that these entrepreneurs are
working in it is totally not it's not my
world if you very kindly called me the
king of the hundred thousand dollar
check I would take the title of king of
the nine dollar a square foot office
space all right so we go and we start
investing in all these companies maybe
talk a little bit about some of the
areas this is all kind of pre blockchain
that that we're doing this talk a little
bit about some of the areas that you're
interested outside of energy obviously
the PR iti and blockchain is what we're
doing now and just some of the
businesses that that you kind of have on
top of your mind yeah so things that are
interesting to me are Technology
robotics you said energy the healthcare
space so healthcare innovation service
innovation
I'm fascinated with CBD distillation
extraction farming if you can imagine I
think it's important and then just hard
sciences so ice tend to spend my free
time and the time I'm educating myself
on investment in that space I've talked
a little bit about quantum biology I
think it's an interesting science that's
as involving it's an important one and
so those are the things I'm kind of
focused on now but again all of that
stuff though it's probably lays into
infrastructure so I'm trying to find the
gaps you know in where where something's
going whether it's an idea a concept
service and how do we how do we get the
tolling like how do we get involved in
the tolling of those concepts for sure
and so as we're making these investments
we invested 62 companies in a year and a
half it was a pretty rapid pace
obviously it's gone very well we're
doing a Starbucks but uh I got to bring
it up
you don't like Starbucks you're a Dunkin
Donuts guy yeah you know we we ended up
at Starbucks because it just had better
Wi-Fi and and I think you like the the
iced coffee there better listen we're
dunks guys I mean value play $2 coffee
I mean I'll stay there all day i I hate
hot coffee I hate it so I really get
iced coffee Jason always gets a hot
coffee and there's been a couple of
times where when we get the Starbucks he
panics and he orders these things off
the menu and it's hilarious to hear him
order you know the frappuccinos white
white chocolate mocha soy or something
yeah and yeah I'm not I'm not great at
that I want to go back to PR GI for a
second because for a year and a half we
pretty much spent every single day
together right and we invested all these
companies and
one day we are driving to Charlotte and
I remember you were going to buy
laundromat a McDonald's McDonald's
actually shout out to the two you
laundry guys at Dan and Alex these two
young founders that they're they're
straight savages right amazing literally
started a laundry business grew very
quickly in Charlotte North Carolina and
they called us and said hey we want to
build our own facility right very
similar to the kind of the fast Med
playbook of kind of vertically integrate
the actual physical infrastructure with
the business on top of it and so you and
I were driving down there and we ended
up buying a McDonald's to build this but
on the way I remember it was the first
time that I ever mentioned to you
Bitcoin cryptocurrency at the area etc
and so just what do you remember about
that conversation skirt school want to
know who has the best URL crypto calm
that's right
crypto calm there are crypto platform
with one goal mother mass adoption
that's why we're all here we're trying
to get crypto in every wallet crypto
calm is helping people do that through
buying earning lending and card payment
everything you could want at crypto calm
go help your boy out
tell them pomp since you download the
app or visit crypto comm pumps got you
always everyone to get into mining and
didn't know how don't worry your boy
comps gotcha everybody got some
electricity and Wi-Fi all you got to do
is go to coin mine comm you buy a coin
mine it's like an Xbox or a Playstation
that helps you turn your electricity
into Bitcoin that's right you purchase
it it shows up at your doorstep you pull
it out of the box you plug it in connect
to your Wi-Fi five minutes or less
you're mining Bitcoin all you have to do
is control it from the mobile app they
provide and then you receive
over-the-air updates that add new coins
and new features on a consistent basis
kind of like how Tesla does over-the-air
updates and updates the car software
just you're updating your coin mind
consumer mining made easy that's right
go to coin mine calm tell them pomp
Sencha and thank me later I remember it
was the first time that I ever met
into you Bitcoin cryptocurrency a theory
ohmic cetera and so just what do you
remember about that conversation yeah it
was the second time someone had pitched
Bitcoin to me so the first time was in
2012 was one of our sales guys that fast
med came to me but I didn't I didn't do
anything with it I think he's crazy well
yeah I mean I was I was this this
particular employee I was working on
focusing him for him to come with this
magic internet money thing it was like
it was the last thing I needed to hear
at that point I was in the car with you
for six hours though as we were going
from Raleigh to Charlotte and you know
it was just at first I was very
contrarian very down on it again I was
you know I I understood game
transactions so in game transactions
because I played video games my whole
life still do so I understood how to buy
things and how digital money worked but
I just wasn't I didn't have the level of
conviction that you did but by the time
we had gotten back to Raleigh
you know I pulled my typical move right
where I said like I have to get my hands
on it also the three hours on the way
there there was a lot of a healthy
banter about this can't be real yes it
is real here's how it works well what
about this and just kind of back and
forth and I remember you were asking
questions that were very obvious you
understood enough to ask the right
questions right kind of appointed well
what if this happens or how does this
work right and it was it was putting
stress on my understanding right because
I was all the questions that we were
first going through were around how do
you hack it like how does this thing
fail like we were really spending a lot
of time on that 51% attack stuff yep and
so we had started to get into the mining
and I remember I revealed to you that I
had bought some mining or a cow super
pissed and I hadn't told Jason that I
did it and and usually we do everything
together but
I was scared he's good the guy was away
two years at Polina yeah that Polina I'm
sorry I'm sorry it's a birthday happy
birthday Polina Polina is uh is my
girlfriend and her and Jason compete
over who who actually is my partner in
life it's and and so I remember I told
you this and you're like well what's
mining and I started explaining it and
we got there and we did the whole real
estate thing and I spent time with the
guys and on the way back it was almost
like you had been like thinking about
the back here ahead and I'll never
forget you was like dude I have a power
source
and ever been like wait what and you
walked me through the idea that PRT I
takes tires puts it through the
scientific process and on the output one
of the outputs is commodities and the
other is a power source and the business
was supposed to sell it into the grid
and receive revenue for that and you had
this like crazy look in your eye like
what if we just use that power to mine
cryptocurrency rather than sell it into
the grid I mean that that was it I mean
that was the establishment of our
investment into building the data center
or the cryptocurrency mining component
of P RTI which you know we believe was
the first waste-to-energy cryptocurrency
- of that type scale in the world and so
I'm very proud of that moment for us and
I mean that was a late 2015 early 16
something like that yeah yeah so I mean
we were very early very fortunate but if
you can imagine you know I I had spent
about nineteen million dollars to build
PRT I so the the to build the mine and
stuff I you know I go all in so you know
we built a very very big
we were actually mining with GPUs at
first and large GPU minor mine and went
through the full spectrum of education
at that point mining aetherium had a
custody it
where do you exchange it why do you
exchange it do you get into altcoins
what are the tax ramifications of all
that how do you source a sick miners you
know learning you know just about power
and and then trying to model out what
does this look like as you continue to
invest this is act like a real estate
investment does this act like Forex and
currency exchange you know it was it was
complicated and fun well the part that I
specifically remember is when we were
doing it we understood how mining worked
we had a sum of 7s JP Burke who was able
to the mining store calm it was able to
help us kind of quickly get up to speed
on you know source hardware but we
bought the rigs that he had under his
dorm room yep we were just at Annie's
hardware that we could find right and we
were buying all this stuff and we put it
together ourselves and well in the part
that I remember was I was driving there
every day and we're doing all this and
her saying to myself like how lucky we
are that not only are we frankly crazy
and convicted enough to do this but
we're doing it at a industrial site
where there's engineers that resources
right I mean that there was there was
guys to level engineers that worked at
PRT I who they loved it right and they
were saying okay holding this part of
the business part my job now how do I
get air flow into the room how do I get
it out did it should a leak chill it
with air conditioner should we build
some sort of sucking mechanism where we
basically suck air through this the room
to create chilled air should we just use
fans and and you start getting into not
just hey can I plug a minor into the
wall you you really get into how do you
build the infrastructure how do you
become energy-efficient how do you
actually taking an ASIC miner and drop
it from 1,400 watts down to something
sub that you know Sue's all of this game
is about low power cost low power
utilization and hash mm-hm and so today
you know and I think of PRT I
I think of not a waste management
business which I think from day one you
knew that's not the business and I don't
even think of it as an energy business
anymore I think of it as a fully
integrated computing platform where you
can basically now power computing power
with energy that is completely off the
grid that you self-generate and you
control and I think that it is probably
one of the most powerful things that
somebody can create is that vertically
integrated computing power that is
self-sufficient
I mean without a data even if you
develop decentralized power generation
you still need access to the grid right
what I'm contemplating and what we've
been able to do is create decentralized
power generation with a parasitic
partner in datacenter mining that we can
Co gen for so we don't even have to have
an interconnect agreement that's a
fail-safe in the event that I wanted to
put power into the grid but we don't
need to we can use that full load of 7
to 10 megawatts of base power continuous
power and put it into compute and here
in the United States the total available
markets around 170 PRT I plants Wow
so that's what we're chasing right now
got it
all right and so as we're doing all this
we get pretty convicted on crypto and
blockchain and Bitcoin before we get
into all of that I want to talk about
some nutrition stuff because for those
of you on Twitter who don't know Jason
eats at Waffle House every single day
and I'll call him and I'll literally
hear him ordering at Waffle House while
we're on the phone explained the Waffle
House situation and what you get and why
yeah so I do this ketogenic diet so I
fast till like 1:00 o'clock every day I
don't eat after 8:00 p.m. drink black
coffee usually in the morning and then I
go to the Waffle House I order six eggs
two slices of cheese two sausage patties
and three slices of bacon and sometimes
if
five ounce sirloin steak every day this
is what that's what I either one o'clock
yeah every day so I went to my doctor to
get an annual physical and and she
almost collapsed when she saw my
cholesterol because it went from like
116 to like 240 she was super concerned
she's like whatever you're doing stop
immediately but then you know I again I
practice medicine for a long time I said
we need to go through the total
cholesterol panel and let's look at the
indices HDL through the roof
triglycerides low total cholesterol okay
so this made me think of a few things
and I need to spend more time on it and
I challenge your listeners to look at
this but I don't think we know [ __ ]
about cholesterol I think if you have
you know [ __ ] about anything well how do
you fair fair point but is cholesterol
in particular I think we know if you
have all of these things out of whack
like your triglycerides are high your
HDL is low your LDL is high your total
cholesterol is high
you probably predisposition for heart
disease diabetes you know a lot of bad
stuff stroke etc but the nuances of
cholesterol I don't think we understand
I think ketogenic diets real I've
noticed not only you know my ability to
keep doing things that I want to do you
know this bit of longevity is there but
in terms of my cognitive abilities I've
noticed some kind of clear a clearness
of my thoughts I also have lost kind of
the I don't know if any of you
experience like midday fatigue or
anything but I was getting that like
around 2:00 o'clock I was like ready to
pass out all that's gone and so I quit
sugar long time ago don't drink soda
ketogenic diet wim HOF breathing and
Waffle House baby so the nutrition is
one piece of it right and we've had
people come on before that talked about
the kind of diet and I think that
generally understood but it's not like
you're in your 40s and it's not like
you're sitting at home you know saying
hey I got some kids and you know where's
the local barbecue this weekend you're
still playing competitive soccer right
you're doing
you work out everyday you've got a lot
of physical activity going on so kind of
describe like what's the impact of all
that physical activity plus building
companies investing and is that a thing
where you're doing the working out
because it helps in that other stuff
where's the thing where it's just more
enjoyable personally yeah I think for me
I think balance is really important and
I think working hard is important like I
people they they talk about work/life
balance I think working hard is good I
don't think there's anything wrong with
that I don't want to shame anyone for
doing that I think taking vacations are
good but I think to really pull this off
in a big way you got to eat right you
got to get sleep you've got to drink
water you know I actually follow I don't
know if any of you follow like this is a
reminder to drink water everyone it's my
favorite account on Twitter yes it's the
greatest thing ever it's like a drink
water idiot did you have water today
and they just insult you into drinking
water breathing I mentioned wim HOF I
think it's it's really interesting
tapping into like your reptile brain
that autonomic automatic nervous system
to be able to control that or call upon
it in some instances is dope so the
combination of all that super important
to me you know 45 just turned 45 tore my
the ACL the last time I tore my ACL I
was 40 playing rugby
semi-pro rugby um you know I still play
competitive soccer lifts you know just
trying to keep going after a you know
I'm not a big Bible guy but there's a
there's a verse that I'm affected by it
it says you know I want to master my
body and make it my slave I think it's
really important because I've been in
situations where my mind has betrayed me
where my body has betrayed me and it's
scary when that happens well and it's
also a thing where you probably have
more control of your body than you do
your mind right and you can use your
mind to control your body so there's a
but when those things fail I don't know
if you've ever beautiful ballplayer I
don't know if you've ever been in the
air before and then been knocked out of
position so when you get in the air and
you're turned mm-hmm something weird
happens one you get the slowness of your
autonomic nervous system you're you're
very hyper aware of that rotation but
then it's scary you don't know how to
come out of it so when you're flipping
or turning those are the type of
situations I've unfortunately
experienced five times and the reason
I'm saying five times I track them five
times I have nine lives I've used five
one and one recently again now the the
fifth one was recent so let's talk about
the Jason was recently I'm going to call
it a plane crash because it's pretty
damn close you just tell a story about
what happened when they on his plane
yeah so it was coming back from Turks
and Caicos with my wife I have three
daughters 16 14 and 11 year old and our
someone who works in our home who
travels with us we were all on this
flight I wasn't able to get seats
together so my wife and I were sitting
together one of my daughter's was with
my our assistant and the other two
daughters were sitting together we were
30 minutes into the flight reached
cruising altitude of 30,000 feet they
just turned the seatbelt lights off and
said we could move around the cabin and
you said a flight attendant yeah I mean
this is serious stuff man I've flown all
my life yeah and there was an explosion
and then this noise it went and the
plane turned to the right and started to
drop and I mean panic on the on the
flight like panic yeah a blur it's not
like hey this is uh this is some
turbulence and all of a sudden about an
explosion on the right side of the plane
and then we're listing and dropping my
wife's freaking like jumping out of her
seat trying to get someplace on the
plane I'm like trying to figure out
instinctively like so stupid but I was
like I would be okay if I was by myself
but I had this dreadful feeling like I'm
not gonna be okay because I can't save
all these people mm-hmm
and then the next 20 minutes was just
bananas well in just to remind everyone
you have three kids between the ages of
11 and 16 yeah they were free place
everybody was freaking out the
stewardesses were freaking out we were
rotating down slowly and you know you on
the back of the seat there was the
flight tracker so I immediately put that
on I wanted to see how high we were in
the speed we were going so we were
descending quickly the plane was slowing
down and we were way off course so we
were we were between Turks and Caicos
and Florida and it looked like the pilot
was trying to go to Miami but then we
were going the wrong direction we turned
we were going back toward Nassau the
pilot eventually gets on the the the mic
and says look what you heard was the
right engine it's no longer functioning
the plane is still flying with one
engine there's a long runway in Nassau
we're headed there but they're
mobilizing the crash fire everyone and
that's why we're turning above I can
only turn to the right and we're just
like getting prepared to crash the crash
land okay as well but we safely landed I
mean we safely landed with one engine
we're the fire crews everything checked
out and we waited in Nassau got another
plane and that was it like it was
literally we fell off the horse no one
wanted to get on another plane but we
couldn't date we weren't immigrated or
we hadn't immigrated into the country
even though I think Nassau is still part
yeah but we weren't even allowed to
leave the room
we had to yeah we had to get on another
plane flew to Atlanta and and then from
there from there it's just regular
flights and everything but yeah it was
wild it was well what what um when
they're like hey we're getting the crash
landing people as precautionary whatever
like
you think I just put my thumb up to the
kids yeah said it's gonna be okay if I
said if we go into the ocean I'll just
get on the wing I'll paddle us back I
can imagine your wife and kids be like
ah you know you know what they're
looking for any type of like they smiled
at me yeah like that's dad yeah of
course that's awesome
all right so let's talk about Bitcoin
blockchain crypto and m1 creeks we're
doing all this mining stuff and we
eventually realized like hey this stuff
is is real and something we're gonna go
focus on and I'll walk it walk us
through the the process from there to to
Morgan Creek well we construct the mine
at PRT I I jump on a plane with my co oh
go to China Hong Kong Malaysia a meet
with Israeli hackers I'm sourcing a sick
miners and parts I want to understand
you know what they're seeing return to
the States you and I continued to deploy
and close Full Tilt capital I think in
total we put about 16 million to work
three million in early-stage and the
rest was in pre IPO and late stage stuff
you you get a call from mark usko have a
few meetings with him bring me into a
few meetings with him we got a hold all
we got to talk about the first meeting
I've met with Mark a couple of times for
coffee and and if you listen to the
episode with him he's kind of told that
story but uh I finally say all right
this is worth me and Jason both going
and talking with mark and trying to to
see if there's something to do here and
Jason and I went to the meeting
separately Jason drove straight from the
PRT I plant and for you you guys can't
see him most likely but he's got a very
beard and he's got a baseball cap on at
the time and he had a construction vest
because you have to safety first on the
plant and obviously gotta have your
reflective vest and the way mark tells
the story is he's sitting in the room
waiting for us to show up and Jason
walks in with a beard a baseball cap and
a construction vest and mark literally
says to himself I really hope that this
guy brings some slight going yeah I mean
literally I mean mark has a traditional
palatial office it's it's beautifully
done I think he built you know a an
office environment that represented you
know the things that were important to
him and it's a professional to a tee you
know and and that's mark anyway and I
show up in construction boots
reflective vest baseball hat beard you
know tatted up like what's up ready to
make money let's go let's go let's go
all right so we ended up deciding that
we're going to to do this with mark in
Morgan Creek what was kind of the
reasoning why you were bullish or a
proponent of it you know I think I think
you and I as CEOs as people running a
small venture fund realized both the
advantages and disadvantages of that
world
well I don't think we could raise
institutional money I thought we had a
very pure and convincing thesis we
understood the infrastructure around
crypto we navigated the world of icos
well and I think mark brought gray hair
and an institutional experience that we
just didn't have plus 40 ft ease plus 15
years of investment experience so he
normalized us in a number of ways that
we would never been able to do I mean
Nouriel Roubini you know his favorite go
to slam when he was trolling us as all
these two are working out of a Starbucks
back
room shutout nor yo what's up yeah where
are you I'm still here
$3,000 Bitcoin that looks pretty good
now how many years to get a four-year
degree at NYU so alright so so we do
this and I think people who have watched
this are listed as 5.5 Jason and Nuria
have a have a great relationship because
Nuria really went hard at at the
Starbucks start of Jason eyes investing
career and what Nouriel doesn't
understand is that we wear that as a
badge of honor and if we could we would
still be in Starbucks whereas I think
Nouriel thinks it's a negative so you're
actually just making our day when you
say that alright I want to switch to as
we start investing you are one of the
only people that I know that has dealt
with the dark side of crypto in Bitcoin
and I will let you tell the story but
essentially you went through a number of
security and hacking incidents that were
pretty scary right so maybe kind of just
tell tell some of that story and then
kind of how it all played out yeah so
those events were all precluded by
another major event which was I think
September 2017 I'm at PRT I my wife
answers the door there are two FBI
agents that have come to my house and
they want to meet with me my wife text
me and says hey this is what's going on
I asked them I get on the phone with
them I say hey what's up they won't tell
me but they want to meet with me so I
tell them we'll meet in Wakefield at the
Dunkin Donuts so on the way there I'm
trying to call my attorney because I'm
like dude you're not supposed to meet
with the FBI like I know that this is
not gonna be good like what but my
attorneys at lunch so that's why you
invited them to your turf dr. jeong's
yeah i knew i could escape if i needed
to know
but but the only thing that gave me kind
of comfort as I walked into the dunks
was look if you always tell the truth
you don't have to remember what you said
so I try to do that so I sit down I've
got a camel a camo hat on ray-bans beard
reflective vests you know my normal look
and I'm sitting in the back of dunks
dude it's like it's like right out of a
movie
guys drive up black truck two guys in
suits beeline right to me like I didn't
even know who I am
they've got a manila folder with them
they said the beard the ray-bans and the
Hat didn't uh it didn't work to keep
them from knowing who you were so anyway
they sit down they're like hey I'm
whatever and this is whoever we want to
talk to you about certain things but
they first want to go through my
background like who what where when why
and how they know about my cars they
know about my patents they know about my
education they apparently had my bank
account records which was concerning
like the you know so I don't think he
can just get that information so they
were looking for something they asked me
about foreign travel all this stuff well
it came down to mining apparently the
FBI had been looking at mining since the
beginning and this was a special darkweb
task force that was based in Charlotte
North Carolina that was looking for bad
actors in the space but also looking for
information in the space and you know I
told him what I was doing I told him why
I was doing it they came out to PRT I
and took a look at it it ultimately
that's what the thing was they were
essentially if I remember correctly they
were basically saying look you've bought
a lot of these yeah they knew millions
of dollars that I sent to China yeah I
said why am be hoarded these computers
they were just like why are you buying
all this compute what are you doing
yep you know so it was I think it was
difficult for them to understand that I
was also running my own power company
they weren't necessarily seeing the
power on the grid you know like if you
were running a math lab the reason they
find you is because of the power
consumption yep they weren't seeing it
it was like all this computes
disappearing same thing in Venezuela
right how did the police figure out
who's mining cryptocurrency even though
it's outlawed they look and see there's
a spike in the energy consumption in the
single home right now that's way too big
of a spike there's got to be something
going say same things happen in Malaysia
right now - they're busting these
clandestine mines that are running so
anyway and just so people remember the
reason why they couldn't see the there
was no spike in energy consumption was
because it's all off the grid itself
generated power yeah so imagine if
someone's importing because I mean this
is me getting rekt but I bought a sick
miners for $2,800 a rig so a small a
sick mine from each 500 rigs so you're
talking 1.4 million dollars worth of
computers that I'm bringing in
you've got aluminum extrusion issues at
the border so they're getting stuck
their pallets of a sick miners like I'm
not off the grid
like everybody's looking saying what are
you doing but anyway so that's it I have
access to the FBI by text message
because they've made themselves
available to me now they're like yo
you're you're legit if you find anyone
doing some crazy stuff tell us and will
you come and speak to our officers about
Manero crypto you know yeah tokens they
come and they do their work and I think
that one they're like okay like we
understand now it all makes sense why
there's no easily traceable
yeah traceable energy consumption we
understand the computers we've seen this
site you know all the stuff like this is
actually pretty cool right we would love
to stay close as you kind of continue
learning and building stuff but also you
know please let us know if we can ever
do anything to help or if there's things
that you know we may ask you to come
educate etc so right so it went from a
hey what the hell's this guy doing - oh
this is actually pretty cool and let's
keep a relationship yeah you know again
my attorney says you never know who the
target of an FBI investigation is so you
know whatever that means that made me
feel better but but then all hell breaks
loose in November so you
I can't recall exactly where I was but
I'll tell you retrospectively this was
always happening on a Saturday night or
Sunday my I think I was in Jamaica
maybe maybe as I forget why I was
definitely overseas it's about 12
o'clock at night 12:00 12:00 a.m. and my
SIM card goes off and I immediately
because I've been you know reading about
this stuff I'm you know I understand
enough I'm like oh crap I'm being sim
swapped so phone goes off I grab my
computer by the time I get to login
they've already changed my passwords so
I've not in my email so now they're
going through the process of changing my
passwords banking etc and and
unfortunately this goes on for a long
time I've I've had a lot of money stolen
from me death threats what was alright
so the first time it happens it is they
essentially get in they sims web you
yeah alright they're able to change
passwords and kind of do what I would
consider is everyone's greatest fear
right which is they get control yeah
right and once they get control they can
do all kinds of crazy stuff you being in
the position of I've now lost control of
my phone number right and some of my
accounts it's not a lot you can do other
than you start calling people and try to
get back control and doing all stuff but
you can't call anyone see this is the
thing most people carry one cell phone
now if I take your cell phone out you
lose cell service you have Wi-Fi so you
can still receive text but for the most
part you're out and this is happening
Saturday night and Sundays so the fraud
prevention departments of AT&T are
closed on Sundays so the hackers know
that if they're gonna sim swap you it's
gonna be on a probably a Sunday once
that goes down they can communicate to
you by text and they have a mirror image
of your phone so any apps you have they
now know where to go
coin base Gemini slush pool so they know
oh you're
a minor and they immediately can do
things so I've had to learn super hard
lessons pomp in regards to all of these
things whether it's hot wallets cold
wallets exchanges mining you know for
example one of the the hard lessons was
if you're mining on slush pool you can
permanently place an address for your
deposits of your mine and lock it
forever and once you do that it cannot
be changed I didn't know that the
hackers did so once they hacked into my
slush pool account they were able to
change that destination and steal a mine
mm-hmm well if you're overseas or
someplace I mean yes screwed what and to
me the part that was crazy was when it
happened it was like whoa we just got a
crash course right because not just you
is everyone around oh yeah I was like
well what just happened how did that
work right and it forced everyone kind
of in our circle to really look at
security in x11 and all the stuff the
second incident right which was where I
think kind of the FBI and more comes in
is I remember all of a sudden you
started frantically texting me saying
like like they're trying to hack me
again right right because I could
recognize when it was happening I would
start getting pained like my passwords
were being changed yeah and I could
defend it so now I have three cell
phones and two computers multiple
services that I'm using and I can defend
myself a little bit here so I could
rapidly change passwords I've locked
some things down I've got dummy apps on
my phone to put people off so I may not
have a bye Nance account but they may
think I do you know so they're wasting
time going after that there's nothing
there well and so what they did is you'd
basically put defense in place and then
what they started to do was rather than
spend the time to hack into all this
just directly threaten you and get you
to engage in giving them Bitcoin right
yeah so they would directly
you know they would attack everything so
your Dropbox accounts but you know
everything your social media accounts
they would solicit investment deals
through my contacts ask for money I
think they did that with you as well
right hey can you send me a few Bitcoin
there were other things that that we
were really concerned about SWAT attacks
so a SWAT attack is where they all say
Jason has shot his wife he address this
yeah he's at there's an active shooter
at his home address
the SWAT team shows up imagine in the
middle of the night and then you're
responding to that he so you have this
fog of war thing going on and people get
hurt they do that to your work as well
so imagine my industrial plant a SWAT
attack so we're worried about that
they've they threatened to kidnap my my
middle daughter and the unfortunate
thing about that when people make
threats it's like whatever but they had
specific information that was really
concerning so when I contacted the local
police department they they thought I
was crazy they're living here today they
showed up to my house but they wouldn't
even come in but I said look this is
what's going on here's the FBI's phone
number because the FBI was on this they
contacted the FBI agents and came in my
house at that point they're like this
I'm way outclassed this is above my
paygrade you can hire me and my buddies
to help give you some protection will
increase coverage in the area put more
patrols here do you have a gun can you
protect yourself I mean it's literally
like I had to turn into some type of
person I'm not like it look I you know I
told you I like to eat right and breathe
but I'm not like the Terminator you know
so but that's what they were expecting
they're like we're not the the police
are not there they can't protect you if
they show up once the bad stuff happens
yeah oh well either while it's going
over after and believe me I love the
police thank you for all you do but you
know you're not standing next to me when
someone tries to abduct my daughter you
know and that's really what they asked
me to do is like hunkered
and and it's scary yeah it's scary
because again it's like my kids on that
plane like what do I do
pomp do I sit down with the family and
say this is probably not real but
someone's trying to kidnap you Molly I
mean I don't think that you do that but
I don't know what their general yeah I
mean I don't think you do that but I
don't know what to do you know I just
don't have as a parent I don't have a
rulebook I don't have the guide for that
so you know I did the best I could
it's frightening I know that they've
they've doxxed and stolen all our
demographic information the whole
families they have all my personal
information so you know at this point
that my mother's maiden name you know
all the things that you think are like a
secret like you're you're going through
a process to validate who you are I just
think it's a joke I mean I literally was
supposed to be on like a celebrity level
protection inside my phone carrier and
they failed I mean they failed it's a
bad situation it's scary how fast
someone can steal all of your
information from a phone carrier how
easy it is to do well I think a lot of
people at this point you just have to
operate as if you're guarantee that your
information is out there because if
someone's got some money got access to
the dark web they're likely to be able
to go by personal information on almost
anybody right there's been so many hacks
at this point of major you know internet
services or mobile insurance Equifax
whatever all those guys yeah that it's
just it's out there right and so you
know it's a really unfortunate scenario
one thankfully that there was you know a
little bit more bark than bite when it
came to a lot of the threats and things
like that but you know there's a story I
think they arrested the kid I got
information from the FBI that they made
an arrest they so we'll see what what
comes out of that but found the person
there's a group but they got one of them
so far so I mean the reason why I wanted
to tell stories which is really
interesting right hackers
and make note got caught yeah that they
can exactly yeah I can't wait to meet
you alright so I want to go from hackers
to Twitter Jason I IND hring Lee call
the gift god which that's gif for those
of you at home who don't know what a gif
is they are the little animated videos
that people post what's the Twitter
strategy what's going on there yeah like
you know pom is a he's a great speaker
as Mark is and they're both great
writers its I'm very envious of that
I've worked hard to try to speak clearly
in my life and and convey messages as
clearly as possible writing them down is
a little more difficult Twitter makes it
really hard right to convey a message
concisely without losing the essence of
what you're trying to say on Twitter
it's an art it really is but even better
than writing is a gif it's like the best
thing ever I literally just have
millions of options to convey my exact
feelings and again you have a skill my
favorite thing that you do is when the
haters come out they and they they
always self select there make it very
obvious that they are are upset you use
the clams where did this come from so
you send gifts claims Maddie nah I just
love to like clam salty clams that
they're clamming just chattering clams
man that's just I love it and unlike
marca I've even noticed that when you
when you hit somebody with six clam
gifts in a row I like what is he doing
and then I really like oh he's calling
you clam he's going salty I got it
that's it uh but you don't block anybody
you don't mute anybody mark and I are
both now in the camp of block early and
often and and just stop the madness but
you engage with them all yeah you know
those that are persistent
and stable they get the clam but I've
really tapped into something a nuance
that I'm missing I was younger when I
was your age when I dropped out of Yale
and started fast med you know I was
working for an orthopedic surgical
practice because I was really my
training I was doing that nights and
weekends to raise money to make all this
work and I had a really dear friend
there his name was Eric Carlson he was a
39 year old orthopedic surgeon and
recently married had a like a
two-year-old daughter and we played golf
together he was like just a great guy
and he put a shotgun in his mouth and
blew himself away
well on his 40th birthday and the
suicide letter said he didn't have any
friends essentially and I was like what
like like I was hurt by that but I also
really started to think man I'm a
selfish bastard like it I didn't
recognize that this guy needed me in
some way I wasn't paying attention I'm
always focused on me me me me me and I
know that a lot of times that impulsive
move the suicide move can be
circumvented by a moment of question or
some person reaching out or doing
something pomme that's kind of resonated
with me at this point in my life so
being a human when someone's coming at
me I'm really just trying to find are
you just a jerk-off
or is there something wrong because a
lot of these people are kids that
they're listening to a lot of
information their whole lives are
focused on themselves you know so it's
very easy to get sucked into depression
and always have social media big time
people are living their best life but
99% of it is nonsense so for me before
you get the clam you're gonna get a
moment of humanity and all I'm doing is
so easy I'm not gonna block you but I am
gonna treat you like a human the until
you get the sauce
the contrast between the humanity and
the clam is an amazing special if you
get clammed up people are gonna go find
the clam gift now they're like ah that's
what he said there's a bunch of them I
know there's a lot of times somebody
would troll me I'll block them and next
thing I know I'm getting notifications
that you're sending clam gifts which I
appreciate I try to defend you guys you
and Mark deserve alright one of the idea
is that that you have I think it's
pretty cool is this idea around the
quantum computing and I think that
quantum computing a lot of times gets
associated with Bitcoin and blockchain
x' and you'll see the people on twitter
who literally say I want quantum
computing comes this is all over right
you have a very interesting view of we
already have quantum computing maybe
describe a little about what you mean
but yeah so a long time ago I was very
very interested in quantum physics so if
you've studied quantum physics it lays
into Buddhism and the philosophies
around there so any of these
unmeasurable or very difficult things to
measure we're really interesting to me
quantum computing some would say exists
today and it exists in the form of
quantum biology so biologic processes
that are at such a small level it's like
if you typed a zero on a page so you
have the typeset and size of a typical
zero if you fit the whole United States
in that zero that's the level that I'm
talking about of size these things
happen like III believe and through kind
of my own studies that that quantum
biology and the processes that are going
on at that level are realer than people
think so quantum computing is probably
not fiction but something that is there
and that computer will look like some
type of chemical soup versus its form
factor that you see today there are
amazing scientific discoveries that are
happening now in the last two decades
that are absolutely incredible there are
some cool books life on the edge you got
to check out that book what's that one
about it's it's a book on quantum
biology so essentially the the the
beginning of the book talks about the
migratory patterns of a European Robin
which lots of animals migrate but what
is so interesting about the migratory
pattern of the European Robin is it it's
not driven by sight or smell or a
repetitive migration these birds can
sense the magnetic fields of the earth
now for something to chemically engage
or biologically engage with a magnetic
field isn't necessarily uncommon that's
just an MRI right what I do with an MRI
is I hit you with a magnet I grab on to
molecules I orient them in a way and
then I drop that magnetic field and it
takes a amazing picture so we know how
this stuff kind of works right again
that an MRI is quantum mechanics or
quantum machine it's it's an example of
it well these birds can actually see the
magnetic field which is crazy right I'm
talking about being able to see magnetic
fields they think it's coming through
like blue light spectrum photons in
their eyes and rods and cones can can
actually see that and I can't remember
the scientists who identified it but
this is all recent stuff I think it's
absolutely amazing
you know and it's part of the thing
that's always been inspiring to me and
why I'm into robotics it's
we have those same kind of mechanisms
and machines that are going on in our
body right now again just the the fact
of us seeing pomp ISM is miraculous
right when you step back and you think
lights going into my eye it's there's an
explosion of chemicals that are engaging
my optic nerve that optic nerve is
transmitting an electric signal into my
brain and then it's mashing up into
chemicals again right the most powerful
computer ever mm-hmm human brain
completely agree and it's one of these
things where I actually believe a lot of
technologists could benefit greatly from
better understanding the science of a
lot of this stuff right if you really
look at even just something simple like
the social platforms that we have the
way that information is consumed the way
that information is passed through
societies etc and if you overlap that
with the scientific understanding of a
brain how a brain consumes information
how it processes it what side of the
brain how does it engage images first
not images right when you really start
to look at the the science behind this
stuff it's powerful information it can
be used for good or bad right so if I
really understand how to make an image
or a statement resonate inside of your
brain I understand the science of what
goes on and somebody else doesn't I
actually have an advantage to bend the
way that you think right and influence
the way that you think and so I think
that a lot of folks are naive and that
we don't understand that suffered they
don't take the time to really learn
because the people who do have that
significant advantage yeah I mean we've
had to face this as investors and as
humans on this planet you and I in
particular you know we invested in a
company that was one of the world's
first to make a complete glass
representation down to the to the neuron
of a brain mammalian brain their pursuit
is one for better imaging techniques but
really what they want to do
is preserved grandma after she passes
away and connect her brain to a computer
and store her memories and harness the
the computing capacity of a brain now
you pitch that to someone in a Starbucks
90% of people are gonna have an ethical
issue with that the other 9% are gonna
say is this gonna be used for evil I
would think and then some will be
compelled to continue to develop the
science you know would you go and get
neural link pomp would you have that
implanted capability so I am convinced
that humanity will all have implants at
some point I think that it's less of a
question of like hey if it was fully
functioning you know Medical Device I
was tested and approved and safe and all
of that I think people are all you know
either lying or tricking themselves as
they say they wouldn't go get it right
right is just the next level biometric
device right you see as long as you're
wearing an eye patch
yeah yeah so you're monitoring some with
this message between it being on my
wrist and under my skin well I would say
it'd be more advantageous for it to be
implanted and if I didn't have to charge
it you don't have to meet you any just
go through all this stuff right right
what if we could recall the internet all
that's on the Internet just by thinking
about it not wearing some device but
actually engaging it so we don't have to
remember or which scientist yeah what do
you think an air pod is doing right it's
getting closer and closer to an
embeddable device and if you didn't have
to put headphones in and take them out
it would essentially be the experience
of you know when somebody has like a
little earpiece in and they're able to
hear talking whether it's on television
or at a show or whatever that you're
able to process information and a
different form factor and a different
mechanism that's super super powerful
but I think the bigger question is not
will you do it it's what is the
milestone that needs to be hit until you
and I say okay I'm ready to do this and
then what
the milestone that needs to be hit for
the mainstream audience to say okay now
this is a consumer you know device just
like getting glasses is a medical
situation
okay now we're all gonna go get implants
right or I'm gonna do it to my kid right
and do that I think that those are the
ethical dilemmas that I'm struggling
with today like you know one of the
things that's most intriguing to me
recently is genomics and and blockchain
right so genomics and blockchain there's
a bunch of companies nebula one of them
then the reason for yeah there's much
right
this guy church is a savage in the space
who is behind that but you know I worry
about protected healthcare information
mmm-hmm like how do you protect not just
my what I did the last time I went to a
doctor but my genetic information okay
how do you really protect that well and
what you're highlighting right I think
is today the world really revolves on
passwords right so how do i permission
myself or others into all kinds of
different software and even physical
locations right on it's passwords now
yeah I made type a password into my
computer I may punch in a you know
four-digit code to get in a door to
access my money right all this there's
pins and passwords basically we are
moving towards a biometric type
situation where the recognition of my
face the recognition of my voice the
recognition of my fingertips right or
our fingerprints that stuff is much more
secure than the passwords may be unless
it gets stolen right or a I get so good
yeah it's easy to basically manipulate
it and so I think that we're headed
towards a world where most likely the
most secure information in order to
unlock things is going to be some sort
of genetic predisposition information
you know something around those genetics
there's a lot of work to be done on
identifying what that stuff is how it
works
he surfaces it how do you keep it secure
at all that has stuff but if all the
sudden genetics goes from like a hey you
know do a twenty three mean I can tell
you where it what countries your
ancestors come from to you can access
your money with those that genetic code
and that genetic information becomes a
lot more important and I don't think
that people are kind of looking around
the corner and realizing how important
it can become over time if you ever
participated in sharing your DNA with
anyone no see I won't do it either I
mean I'm sure it's out there somewhere
but I just won't do it for that reason
it's like the ultimate identifier if you
can go through a multi multi stage multi
factorial biometric screen eyes
fingerprint facial recognition voice
tone intonation but the DNA is probably
the only way to do it right it's that's
the foolproof way but can you copy
someone's DNA well and for me so I can't
say add some master plan as to why do
the did DNA stuff I'm just cheap right
it was like three hundred bucks and I
paint three hundred care where my
ancestors came from I'm Italian I've
been a time my whole life if I find out
anything different be mad that was
really why I didn't do it at first but
eventually when I started to hear the
stories of you know hey look is this DNA
information being sold to companies is
it being given and processed in other
country I mean look what happen recently
where one of those companies that does
like ancestry and I think it may be
called living tree or something they
turned over their files to the FBI
mm-hmm who then went through it looking
for criminals mm-hmm I don't regardless
of whether you're criminal or not I
don't think that's why those people
shared their DNA of course with that
company yeah well and it brings a bigger
question right is not only what
companies get your DNA information but
what information should these companies
have on you at all right and it's the
genetic data is kind of the most
sensitive probably the most valuable
because it is impossible to replicate
for you right
and the kind of genetic signature whew
oh well but there's other information
right that we give very easily or any
night and I continue to just think just
your location data right just giving
that to services because it makes it
more convenient has ramifications that I
recently saw somebody was tracked down
so I don't remember exactly how it works
but basically there's a shadow GPS
essentially on your cell phone
the cell phone company has that
information it's kind of like the last
tower you ping type thing they sell that
data
I believe it's anonymized but they sell
that data of a company there's a woman
who is suing one of the I think it's a
cellphone company because somebody
bought the data and was able to track
her down or use it to locate her
supposed to be anonymized must be all
stuff all she did was have a cell phone
right she's not thinking about can
somebody who's a bad actor you know I
don't remember all the details but by
getting this cell phone I didn't know
that I was gonna put myself in physical
safety risk that's what she did right
and it's pretty scary when you start to
think of all the data that you generate
they we just hand over to other
companies because we don't even realize
yeah I don't think that the cell phone
companies understood the the level of
security that they really needed to put
in place when they did what they did
which is they have all your financial
data they have all of your demographic
information and then the cell phone is
essentially your mobile wallet mm-hmm at
that point it's such a point vector of
attack like a an issue that you have to
resolve you almost have to go through a
regression of technology back to analog
to protect yourself flip phone pager
smart phone needs to be air locked or
air gapped then you a night you know you
know that's what I kind of do the
airplane mode it's imported it to is
what have you answer your phone
if it's a number I don't know No
never never and part of its robocalling
some of its because I don't ever go with
it I just said unless I unless it comes
up as someone that I know I never answer
the fire same and I don't have a voice
mail setup no voicemail right it's just
look if you need me you'll figure it out
the other thing too is as these devices
become more and more embeddable or or
get closer to being embedded I think a
lot about what happens when the digital
wallet is embedded in our body right or
you've got some sort of embeddable in
your brain and there is that security
component of well could it get hacked
right and I remember as a kid I wish I
remembered the movie but there's a movie
and the vice-president has a pacemaker
and basically you know the plot is
somebody gets into the office and they
go and they find the box that that
pacemaker came out of and they get the
serial number somebody hacks the
pacemaker they basically kill the vice
president right you know that that hack
has happened but not with pacemakers it
was with insulin pumps really you should
read about that there they've hacked
insulin pumps and as you can imagine
that kanjis are jacking up the insulin
that's injected I don't know what they
did but I know that there was a
vulnerability in insulin pumps for hacks
so these are really relevant discussions
yeah and it's scary super scary right
you know and I always go to I forget
yourself like what if your child right
or your father or your mother or
somebody you love that happens to them
right because to yourself you're kind of
like a look at you know you have the the
bias of believing that it won't happen
to you right but is what if it having
somebody that you know and all of a
sudden the insulin just gets jacked up
and sup you know killing them
now it's crazy and it's not acceptable
so we have to come up with with
solutions to this stuff we have to come
up with solutions for sure one of the
last things I want to talk about is a
universal healthcare because you've got
this this deep background in healthcare
and understand what I would consider
more kind of boots on the ground view of
how health care in America works today I
will caveat the question with I was
listening to a Joe Rogan's recent
podcast with Bernie Sanders right
and admittedly my my view of a lot of
the rhetoric and kind of the ideas was
was not super positive right from what
he did but in listening to it it was
very interesting to hear him talk about
US health care verse Canadian health
care the cost the quality who pays the
cost etc and it reminded me a lot of the
universal health care conversation in
the United States
what what's kind of your take on the US
healthcare system is things like
universal health care possible
are they net benefit net negative how do
we compare it other countries just kind
of like how do you think about this like
on a more structural you know kind of
platform for US health care yeah so I'll
start the the kind of discussion that I
think health care is a right human right
not a privilege I'm also gonna say that
in the United States we actually do a
fantastic job of providing health care
to people and I will always defend my
position by doing this if you feel right
now you're having some type of medical
issue emergency what have you if you
call 911 we'll come and provide you with
the basis basic health care they will
triage you and potentially transport you
to a US emergency department where
they're obligated to provide you
treatment without proving a source of
pay so right there you're so far ahead
of most countries that don't have a
universal health care system all right
on top of that the United States really
expedites procedures like we're super
good at getting things done if you need
an MRI you can pretty much get an MRI
whereas if you travel around the world
it becomes less less obvious less
available Canada you know you're going
to be in the queue in Europe you're in a
queue
Procedures joint-replacement it's not
gonna happen you're gonna be putting a
queue in the United States you're gonna
get access to it but you're gonna need
health insurance for that so my the my
general feeling is health care is a
right not a privilege can we do
universal healthcare we've got a really
good system in place now it could be
made better we need to figure out a way
to not exclude people with pre-existing
conditions that is just a non-story
you've got to be able to provide an
insurance program for everyone that
being said the healthy of us have to pay
you know so I'm not one that is afraid
to pay taxes and I would go so far as to
say put a health care tax in place I'm
ok with that and and provides some basic
level of health care to every US citizen
I don't think that's undoable do you
think that's undoable do you think that
the quality of care that is provided
today is too expensive no it's fraught
with too many errors ok so there's a
tremendous amount of wasted dollars in
health care and due to medical errors
and the numbers extraordinary I don't
want to misquote it it's greater than 20
percent it may be 30 40 percent of US
health care dollars are spent on issues
fraud mistakes medical mismanagement
there's it's just a mess pop when I
started in health care we were working
with paper systems it moved on to
something called a tea tea chart which
was essentially a humonculon where we
pulled we pulled a piece of paper that
was specific to the disease process in
the area of the disease and now we have
electronic medical records patient
portals integrated healthcare systems
bi-directional interfaces around
technology but it's still a mess because
one hospital system can't talk to the
next one private physician who's outside
of that healthcare organism can't
communicate with it so there's still
sing paper around so there's I mean that
that's what we're dealing with today
so the potential of blockchain
technology enhancing this healthcare
system and decreasing fraud decreasing
pharmaceutical issues decreasing
miscommunication of medical errors could
could be a boom for for health care and
and find dollars that were already in
the system mm-hmm use them appropriately
and do you feel like when you say errors
is that like fraudulent stuff where
people are basically lying and there's
money changing hands etc or is that more
a structural issue where one of the
things that Bernie Sanders talked about
in the podcasts that I did not know is a
lot of the drug companies are able to
manipulate the prices and rise prices
without competition and also without
warning right so today you can go and
you can buy a drug and come back three
weeks later worse than that it's worse
than that I wish I could sit down with
Bernie and really tell them about what
PBMs do so when you go to the pharmacy
and you present your your insurance card
for a certain drug whether it's brand or
generic if it's a brand-name drug there
are tiers tier 1 2 3 4 etc that PBM was
supposed to find you the lowest cost for
that drug it's not it actually does the
reverse it gives that particular retail
pharmacy the highest price that they can
build the insurance company for for the
drug for example I picked up a
prescription recently for for something
and the price of it because it was out
it was outside of my insurance it was
$300 the the pharmacy tech goes hold on
a second I think I have a coupon for
that and she goes yeah we do 30 bucks
and I go okay stop you know that's
that's amazing I have to get this every
month you're telling me you just took a
prescription I have to pay $30 $300 a
month for down to 30 what is this it's a
program called good rx
I think that's the name of it good rx
it's essentially is someone very smart
went into the PBM and helps you find the
correct lowest price for that particular
drug and they print it out as a coupon
it's a 90% discount simply because
somebody actually looked at the right
price the price that didn't it wasn't
incentivized in the wrong way profit
over healthcare profit over integrity
profit over morality profit over
everything good about health care you
know it's about profit on top of that
CVS can sell liquor and candy and
[ __ ] you know well the the regular
doctor or me that was competing against
retail retail pharmacies that had urgent
cares inside of him I don't sell
KitKat's
yep how can you even do that well it
goes this idea of when they used to sell
cigarettes to and they sell jewel
probably shoot a gradual nah
are you sure can if you want so we
looked at the jewel investment and we
passed
Jason is uh is two for two on passing on
multi-billion dollar companies that are
in and around healthcare in science both
of which ended up having issues will
start with with with their nose with the
first one which is that their nose maybe
tell that story real quick yeah so this
is two thousand two thousand twelve two
thousand eleven two thousand twelve
BlueCross BlueShield actually asked me
to do diligence on thier nose flew out
met with I think his name's Balaji it
was a CEO who was eventually dating
Elizabeth which I didn't know at the
time went through the full full business
I was intrigued with her claims that
they could do two thousand laboratory
tests from a finger stick you know I've
been practicing medicine for a long time
and you know this was one of two things
either a miracle invention where she had
a box that could do this off a finger
stick or they were they were using mass
Vectra photometry or gas chromatography
there had to be some real science behind
it to to do this and I I didn't think
you can get the results from a finger
stick so I flew out to the west coast to
to meet with them and they wouldn't show
me the technology I mean it was that
simple pump again it's what I said to
you before I have to touch things see
them interface with them if you want me
to invest in a jacket company will get
me the jacket you know let's see what
this thing looks like they wouldn't show
it to me and let me tell you there were
some heavy hitters that are already
invested at that point I mean you had
just major people on their board etc and
Elizabeth was a very compelling a very
compelling and convincing young woman I
went back we pass on the investment and
then the second is is Jewel and when we
looked at that it was almost an
immediate these guys are in get in
trouble with regulators you can't sell
this to kids yeah I looked at the
packaging you know when you tell him a
flavored tobacco you know it just
reminded me of when I was a kid in
Queens you know I'd go to the corner
store and you'd buy like candy
cigarettes just the fact of me saying
you could buy candy cigarettes is
ridiculous candy cigarettes come on you
can't do that and I mean they spank the
the cigarette companies hard yeah I mean
they're crushing them out of business
right now with golden leaf etc the
penalties are extraordinary Jule it will
if not has faced the same demise mean
it's just and I don't know it's just not
the right thing yeah absolutely well and
it brings me to this point of holistic
health care right where if you really
look at yeah I do it all the time I've
got a bunch of friends now that are
having kids and they're kind of you know
I'll say newborn to five maybe some we
have six seven year olds right that I'm
close with and you see the photos and
their kids are you know they're not
grossly obese but they're not skinny
right and there's a couple of these
photos you look at you're like actually
that kid every time I see a picture I'm
got ice cream in his hand right or has
got you know candy ORS got something on
his mouth that's green and blue and
and doesn't look like natural food right
and you kind of start to realize like
would we be better off simply going to
your point of like maybe we don't sell
the candy and all this other stuff in
the same place where we sell the
medicine to then cure the stuff that
came from the candy right we'll be
better off teaching people from a very
young age that look sugar can absolutely
ravage your health over a long period of
time right the things that you put in
your body are important to have you know
an impact and not even just saying like
hey don't eat candy but actually
explaining this is what is
scientifically happening in your body
when you eat this right and could we
educate people into being healthier
because frankly I'd never got any of
that education right in the traditional
schooling system you just what's two
plus two
right how do you write and how do you do
this but but never anything that
actually you know could have a massive
impact on on a national scale if
everyone was educated about things we
were put in our bodies yeah I think I am
the most hope than I ever have around
this this call for transparency with
your generation and you've had access to
more information than any any person
that's ever walked the planet and and
and I think you all have figured out
some legacy problems that my generation
and those before didn't understand
you're marrying differently you're not
getting divorced as frequently I think
you will be a healthier population I
think you're incredibly ambitious and
you're incredibly smart and have created
amazing businesses but this this is
about transparency and there's some
really cool science out there now about
adding energy to food and
bioavailability I mean at another time
I'd love to talk about that if you
charge or reorient molecules correctly
they become more bioavailable and our
food has been so processed and so
denatured that you just don't get the
power that it used to give you when you
eat it if you can replace that power
which I think there are technologies
I can do that now we're kind of back in
the quantum science quantum biology
world things change the effectiveness of
drugs you can decrease the dosage
increase the bioavailability you can do
that with food you can do that with a
number of things so I think it's an
amazing time to be alive you've said
that a number of times I think I think
Bitcoin is is is real and and I think
some of the issues that we're facing
right now as a population on this planet
are real and you know I hope we take
them seriously the before I do the rapid
fire many don't know but a your favorite
music group wu-tang clan where where the
obsession come from wu-tang yeah yeah no
thanks for finally giving a shot out to
wu-tang clan I'm a I'm a much more NWA
no whoo tang clan so coming out of high
school in Florida we were listening to
like Miami bass so I got to my freshman
year at Methodist my roommate was a
soccer player from Edison New Jersey and
he literally had like dose effects onyx
and wu-tang clan I've never heard it
before
and so as soon as I heard it it was it
was over like Method Man Raekwon the
chef goes face killer you know it was
just too much man and then that's 25
years crazy 25 years if you get a chance
to watch the Showtime
there's four episodes of I think it's up
mics and Men it really is great it's
fantastic
it's about whoo tang clan and they're
just the way they approach music and
they're still relevant today I mean I
just heard a new whoo tang song
yesterday with the GZA and some new
relevant guys I mean it's incredible
it's crazy it's crazy it's absolutely
crazy so yeah whoo tang for the
rapid-fire most important company in
crypto or Bitcoin the most important
company in crypto and Bitcoin now I've
answered that before it's Bitcoin
it's Bitcoin what's the one regulation
you would change or improve if you could
man I'd get rid of qualified purchase or
credit investor I absolutely hate it I
just think it's wrong I think it's wrong
I mean look I'm doing this stuff today
this whole fund business investing and
working to help my friends and and
people who believe in this thesis to
getting access into venture and private
equity because their only options were
to have a job to become self-employed to
me you know to become a business owner
or to potentially make enough money to
invest and I think those are all okay
but they're not the same as the returns
that these venture guys are getting and
I couldn't get access to to that you
know now I can but you you get there by
being successful I don't think that's
fair I think anyone should have the
chance to look across the room and say
you know what i think i think lift is a
good investment
like I like using it I'd like to own
that company and they should be allowed
to buy that mm-hmm
you know they should be able to buy it
on the pre-ipo and she have access to it
well and they can own it in the public
market only after the largest returns
have already been captured now of all
the values been extracted prior to it
going into the public market and you're
seeing that now especially as companies
they private lasers they private yeah
you're seeing that now so it's just not
fair
yeah it's not fair I change that what's
the most controversial thing you'll say
encrypter Bitcoin so when people hear it
they will disagree with you most
controversial thing that I say and
crypto that people disagree with me yeah
it was the most controversial thought
you have hmm
oh no I don't like a Bitcoin SV guy no
not at all
not at all but most controversial
thought yeah I don't I don't know if I
have a real controversial position in
Bitcoin you know that the thing that
happens to us unfortunately is we're
kind of like in this micro environment
where it's a big world for us like so
you know I'm always sorting out
everything but it's really small still
you know it's really small you know it
the most controversial thing for me is
probably where I think it's going you
know and I try to tell people this is
one of those moments that you should you
should go all-in on and I think that's
what's controversial II just don't see
it most important book you've ever read
you know it's probably this is a great
question actually this is a great
question it's probably a culmination of
a number of books so when I was a little
kid and I don't even know what the title
of these books are pop but there were
books that while you read them you could
be on like page 30 and it would give you
a choice like if you choose a go to page
50 if you choose B I loved it it was
like I could change the scope though
they could change the the path of what
was happening so I used to read those
books all the time and then it's like
the road less traveled seven habits of
highly effective people think it's like
Covey and pack you know I and those
books really kind of framed my
perspective Rich Dad Poor Dad
yeah I love all that stuff aliens
definitely I a Lian's in the mood yeah
well let's like aliens I think are
totally they're like I mean if we spent
more time together you'd understand like
my whole feelings about life like the
only reason like one of the things that
we haven't been able to do is make life
from rocks but life is rocks right the
same parts and components that are in a
rock are life we just haven't figured
out what drives that life force right
but you have things like organelles in
your body right now
that are bacteria that weren't parts of
you like a mitochondria a mitochondria
has its own [ __ ] like it's its own power
house it's got its own kind of DNA it's
it's a bacteria but it's inside your
cells so you've you've brought that in
so we can make you live and be the
person you are so aliens don't look like
I think we think they look but they're
everywhere mmm so they're here here
they're here on the planet they're
everywhere they're in every every part
of the universe you know and when the
fourth nation India lands their rover on
the moon on September 7th you know I
hope they find life you know I'm so
excited for them that they're doing that
he's coming up it's September 7th you
know India that's pretty awesome yeah I
think they may be in orbit around the
moon right now but it's it's amazing I
you know do you think it's a thing where
there's life on other planets and out in
the solar system and we either haven't
seen it yet or we don't have the tools
to actually identify it or do you think
it's something where we have the tools
and we're looking but it's Rob ibly not
in this solar system it's in a different
solar system yeah I think it's beyond
our technology at this point but I think
we are still struggling with what space
travel I mean I I think this please
correct me if I'm wrong but I thought
this was ridiculous the the spaceship
that's going from India to the moon it's
taking 20 days for them to get there and
I think that's right but in 1969 when
the u.s. landed on the moon was people
it took four days allegedly four days I
don't understand why we were able to do
it so much more rapidly and why we were
able to land on the moon with humans
with very limited technology as compared
to India launching today and not putting
a person on the moon there they're
literally going into a low orbit and
land
I think a rover on the moon you know III
don't think that our instrumentation is
is subtle enough to pick up life maybe
that like life in the way you're asking
me the question but I think we found
water and I think bacteria are
everywhere area 51
I think there's anything there yeah
definitely but I would not storm it I
think that it's just a mistake please
don't do that I mean I mean the guy
who's dressed like a wizard is amazing
but he's gonna get clam I guess don't do
that yeah everybody wants their I think
there's advanced propulsion I mean when
you think about you served in which war
Iraq Iraq yeah what what year 2008-2009
right so the first Gulf War
mmm-hmm that's when we put stealth
technology out that technology was from
1970 mmm-hmm we we showed it in Gulf one
that's when we first showed the
technology at twenty something years
later or is stealth technology right
stealth bombers still fight or what have
you there is absolutely no way we don't
have aircraft that can go up down left
and right using different types of
propulsion systems magnetics etc so you
know that's what's out in those testing
grounds those are those are advanced
warfare technology I don't know if there
are aliens there well the thing that
other spacecraft that that are there
that may have crashed that nobody needs
to say yeah I mean look that there's
also there are human pilots on that yeah
and to me the thing that is so
interesting is everyone is focused on
the warfare everyone is focused on the
aliens and kind of all of these like
frankly things that are really cool to
think about right but
about like you know I don't know CRISPR
technology and genetic editing and
things that it's not hey I can fly
something over your country right I'm
talking about changing the human
population at earth in a way that could
be very drastic and create an inflection
point either positive or negative
where's that research happening yeah it
is happening
nanotechnology embeddable x' these like
shrink you down to some type of device
and embed that it's all here mm-hmm it's
all here
you know I think was meltem that was
watching the matrix recently and saying
like how forward-thinking and powerful
that movie is because it really is I
would challenge you to watch the matrix
again in this series that stuff is is
more real than it's not they nailed it
yeah definitely
all right coming up on two and a half
hours well one question do you have for
me I want to ask the real one so now I'm
gonna ask now I'm gonna ask so first cup
two question I have two questions what
do I have to cut off the pot no question
since I won what did you get Polina for
a birthday I I haven't given it to her
yet Saul wait till uh till I give it to
her all right
recording this and I haven't gotten
plana her gift yet so I I actually have
no answer that's just priorities man I
like Polina is super important I want to
be happy that's important person
appreciates you yeah I want to be
invited to the wedding she's also gonna
now tell me oh it's so nice adjacent to
talk about me on the podcast so perfect
now Polina sushi sharp C sharp alright
you're lucky guy I appreciate it I'll
make sure that she knows that chef I
listen to this twice now and and cut up
the audio and then playback for me to
remind me at times she's she's sent an
else man all right great great a great
podcast
Jason wants to ask when I'm getting
married that's right that's right I just
want to go to the wedding I think it'd
be fun so I've actually never talked
about this on here but I'll see ya I
don't believe in big weddings I don't
think that that's like kind of doesn't
have to be big man I just want to be
there I kind of think that when I get
married I might just get married with
nobody there yeah why not I did okay so
I want to be like you
perfect I mean I did my wife and I got
married in Hawaii it was just her and I
yeah would you do it again
Yeah right without anybody knowing a
soul as I'm saying no hassle no
pressures I know anything is just you're
there with a person that it's all this
between you and them that was nice
we had a real ceremony everything it was
just it was just to us why not I just
want to be there man the wolf FaceTime
you from Mars oh my god all right listen
I appreciate coming and doing this I
think people will will enjoy it so
thanks so much for everyone to listen to
this I know it's a long one but
hopefully you enjoyed it yeah thanks
very much hey everyone pop here if you
like this episode of off the chain and
want to help us to take Krypto to the
top of the Apple Spotify and other
podcast charts please do us a favor and
rate review and subscribe to review
simply go to the off-the-chain home page
scroll down until you see the five blank
stars taking 15 seconds to fill those
stars in and leave a quick review goes a
long way and helping us take the entire
Krypto ecosystem to the top of the
charts I appreciate you listening and
see you next time on off the chain